offensive in Bergen thank you chasing
your 20 folks Grand Slam title
Megan Marco well reportedly watch gal
pals Serena Williams compete at
Wimbledon marking only her third public
appearance since giving birth to Archie
on May 6 but why is this so significant
you asked we're doing a deep dive into
all the reasons have you had any chance
so far to talk to your friend Megan
Markel about kippers maybe some
parenting advice so pass on some words
of wisdom I never pass on words of
wisdom because I feel like everyone when
they have a kid especially when you just
have a baby it is so difficult to just
be and you know it's just like give
through the first three months and then
four months and then we can talk Syrena
chatting with the BBC at the tennis
tournament
we're told Megan will attend according
to our source the only thing that could
change the Duchess's plans is if the
baby keeps her home last minute I have
the two best guys in the world so I'm
really
Megan is laid low ever since welcoming
her first son with hubby Prince Harry
with one major exception to attend the
Queen's trooping the colors birthday
celebration back on June 8th I'm told it
was really important to Megan it was her
way of paying her respects to Her
Majesty the Queen of course there was
also her surprise appearance with Harry
at Sunday's first-ever regular-season
major league baseball game in London
she rocked a fabulous belted blank
Stella McCartney dressed for the
occasion and chatted with players from
both the New York Yankees and the Boston
Red Sox Megan is bowed out of all other
public appearances except for those two
events this includes president trumps
state visit in early June which she left
Harry to attend solo there will be the
old engagement that whatever is
important to the couple of Megan can be
there my palace sources tell me not to
expect Megan to return to work full-time
until the four sarena
and Anji Kerber walking out you're just
really are taking a deep breath and
trying to be calm at the stage it's
worth noting that Megan also showed up
to last year's Wimbledon in support of
Serena
the outing marked her first solo event
with sister-in-law Kate Middleton she's
done this you are superhuman super mama
no I'm just I'm just me and that's all I
can be but to all the moms out there you
know it was playing free today and I
tried it's obvious Meghan in Serena's
friendship runs pretty deep remember the
boss lady blazer making war in Australia
the day after blessing us with her first
maternity look that was from Serena's
new clothing line and it sold out after
Megan was photographed in it I think
it's really important to define yourself
and to defy labels and to be yourself
meanwhile Serena and her hubby Alexis
Ohanian were guests at Meghan in Harry's
2018 wedding she helped throw mm lavish
New York City baby shower earlier this
year and check out this photo of Meghan
and Serena at DIRECTV's beach bowl in
2014
Serena's friendship aside tennis itself
seems to hold a special place in
Meghan's heart she and Harry actually
made their couple debut back in 2017 at
it Invictus games wheelchair tennis
match are you seeing the common themes
yet we can't wait for Meghan's Wimbledon
appearance
[Music]